maintenant l'acte unique cette première
avril m'étais dit ce n'est pas à toi
c'est un patrick poivre d'arvor pas
commencé enfin tu es folle tu vois bien
qu'il ait valeur les talents peine
chacun son métier alors allez vous
asseoir tous les deux et puis tout à
l'heure on dira pourquoi vous êtes
aujourd'hui à paris ce 1er avril
d'accord d'accord merci patrick est
d'abord bonjour à tous alors avant de
retrouver nos petits camarades d'un soir
nos invités du 1er avril
nous allons traiter sérieusement je vous
promets l'actualité du jour actualités
essentiellement internationale avec un
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux au
tchad avec les images de la
manifestation des paysans français en
grande bretagne avec de nouveaux détails
que le rat françois qu'on est sur la
filière terroriste franco italienne est
avec en premier lieu des informations
venues d'iran le pad de entre washington
et téhéran se poursuit avec aujourd'hui
un peu plus de pas en avant que deux pas
en arrière
cela avait assez mal commencé à l'aube
avec le non catégorique de l'ayatollah
khomeini aux propositions carter
discours très dur dans sa forme mais qui
ne fermaient pas complètement la porte à
des négociations le président la
république monsieur bani sadr à lui
poussé un peu plus cette porte et a
promis que le conseil de la révolution
allait désormais prendre le contrôle les
otages américains
jusqu alors aux mains des étudiants et
ce jusqu'à l'ouverture du prochain
parlement
alors puisque c'est comme ça a dit la
maison blanche nous allons surseoir à
l'imposition de sanctions
supplémentaires philippe rochot le sort
des otages américains s'est peut-être
joué ce matin sur la place de la
libération à téhéran l'ancien place shia
d' ils étaient près de 500 milles pour
fêter le premier anniversaire de la
révolution islamique l'ayatollah
khomeini fatigué avait délégué son i
pour lire son discours un discours très
dur pour les américains mais où le chef
religieux déclare que le sort des otages
ne peut être réglée que par le peuple
iranien
donc par le parlement m une heure plus
tard dix points de suture sous du chef
de l'état monsieur bani sadr qui annonce
que le conseil de la révolution prend en
charge les otages américains à condition
que les états unis renoncent à de
nouvelles sanctions contre l'iran
en clair cela signifie que l' affaire
des otages la passe est aux mains des
autorités légales iranienne et que leur
sort ne dépendra plus des étudiants
islamiques qui les tiennent prisonniers
de novembre à l'ambassade américaine a
laissé précision le temps carte du chat
et de jimmy carter tendue en effigie des
militants espagne accuse monsieur
benissad de trahir les paroles de l'imam
khomeiny ils savent que si les dotations
remis au pouvoir légal qui seront
libérés à plus ou moins longue échéance
car cette affaire embarrasse les
dirigeants iraniens
plus que jamais c'est donc la lutte
ouverte entre deux centres de pouvoir à
téhéran
l'autorité légale et les étudiants
islamiques
mais cette fois les étudiants semblent
contraint de laisser le nouveau
parlement qui doit se réunir en juillet
décider du sort des otages américains
pendant ce temps le chat qui doit suivre
de très près encore ces événements va
assez mal le concert qui le touchent
encore progresser le mal a atteint le
foie tchad retraite des congolais qui
essayer d'apaiser les différentes
factions qui se déchire à n'djamena les
français pendant ce temps installé eu au
cameroun mais non loin de la capitale
tchadienne un hôpital militaire de
campagne
voici maintenant comme promis le
reportage que nous adresse du tchad
patrick clément et j'adorais
25 km entendre le plus chez la piste de
dia mais là les avions français sont
obligés de volée au ras des arbres à 50
mètres pas plus de cette terre fait de
latérite offre et surtout de poussière
jaune
à 50 mètres seulement oui au dessus du
sol parce que à cette altitude les
transall qui gênent ravitailler la
capitale tchadienne ont peu de chances
d'être touchée par les fusées soldats
ehrsam de fabrication soviétique qui
sont utilisés indifféremment par les
onze tendance qui s'affrontent ici
depuis plusieurs années
alors qu'à quelques centaines de mètres
d'ici les tchadiens ne cesse de remettre
en question des cessez-le-feu plus
miraculeux les uns que les autres
cette base en boudin au port
international contrôlé par dix ans
parachutiste français est une zone de
calme presque surréaliste
elle a permis l'évacuation des européens
il n'en reste aujourd'hui que
quelques-uns il refuse de partir ceux
qui sont évacués aujourd'hui sont des
diplomates étrangers
cette base aussi permet aux médecins
français de sauver les guérilleros ce
qu'ils réussissent à y parvenir
ici on pratique surtout une chirurgie
d'urgence docteur êtes ici depuis
combien de temps au tchad au mois de
juin ça fera 15 vous allez donc assisté
peu près tous les combats
à peu près
et c'est la première fois que vous voyez
un tel paroxysme c'est la première fois
et effectivement on voit autant de
blessés les tentes dressées aussi grave
ceci lui ou l'armement sophistiqué qui
arrivent de plus en plus dans ce pays
alors depuis le début de ces combats
pour cette troisième guerre civile
tchadienne presque 2000 marc 2000 morts
que l'on trouve autant du côté du sénat
breake de son grand rival beaucoup ni
hisséne habré goukouni et quelques
autres qui comme des barons féodaux se
taillent ici des fiefs grands coups de
mortiers de bazookas et de canon sans se
soucier de massacrer une population
civile qui réellement à l'heure actuelle
ne croit plus en rien sauf en la fuite
dans les pays limitrophes tragique
épilogue de l'enlèvement d'olivier
brault à papeete le fils d'un des hommes
d'affaires les plus riches de polynésie
avaient été tuées en fait le jour même
de son enlèvement ce sont trois
apprentis gangsters qualifié de minable
par les enquêteurs qu'ils ont matraqué
et qui ont ensuite tenté de faire
disparaître le corps en l'incendiant les
poussant le cynisme jusqu'au bout ils
ont téléphoné à la compagne de lies
vibrer au pour avoir une ans olivier
bréau 26 ans était le demi frère de la
femme de sacha distel terrorisme
l'italie vient de demander l'extradition
des jeunes gens arrêtés la semaine
dernière à toulon ceux ci viennent
d'ailleurs d'être transférés sous
escorte militaire assez impressionnante
à paris par ailleurs la police a réussi
à identifier mais pas encore arrêté les
auteurs présumés du mitraillage du
ministère de la coopération qui étaient
des membres du réseau action directe
alors françois corner les détails sur
ces réseaux et sur la manière dont les
policiers réussissent à remonter les
filières françaises italiennes mais je
crois tout d'abord qu'il ne faut pas
confondre brigades rouges italiennes
fraction armée rouge en allemagne et
action directe en france
certes la lutte armée existe bien dans
l'hexagone elle s'est manifestée par de
multiples sabotages mitraillages ou
plasticage mais tout cela n'a aucune
commune mesure avec la sphère aldo moro
en italie par exemple ou l'exécution
danse martin schleyer en allemagne en
france le terrorisme révolutionnaire n'a
jamais dépassé le stade embryonnaire il
a commencé après mai 68 avec la
naissance d'un mouvement maoïste la
nouvelle résistance populaire qui se
signalent par des attentats à l'explosif
viennent ensuite les galeries groupe
d'action révolutionnaire international
qui depuis la france lutte contre le
franquisme
puis l'ena pape noyau armée pour
l'autonomie populaire
eux seuls sont allés jusqu à travers un
homme et à revendiquer leur geste
c'était le 23 mars 77 jean-antoine
tramoni un vigile de chez renault qui
avait abattu pierre overney au cours
d'une distribution de tracts devant
l'usiné renault était assassiné à la
porte de son domicile après le
démantèlement des nappes ap
un autre mouvement prend le relais ce
sont les autonome mélange d'anciens
maoïste d'anarchistes et de loubards de
banlieue ils brisent les vitrines
agressent des magistrats ce sont les
fameux de casseurs au fil des années les
mêmes terroriste qui passe d garé au
napa puis aux autonome perdent de leur
efficacité à chaque fois ils espèrent
trouver un souffle nouveau
en changeant d'organisation et de sigles
dernier amateurs de ce mouvement
terroriste le groupe d'action directe
qui fait nouveau se rapproche des
organisations internationales et
notamment des brigades rouges
on retrouve dans ce groupe action
directe bon nombre d'étrangers des
italiens bien sûr mais aussi des
espagnols
il y as collusion certaine dans ce
terrorisme européen faux papiers planque
argent très mobile les groupes flirte
avec la grande délinquance hold up pour
financer les réseaux européens
en fait tous ces groupes terroristes en
france sont un peu flou difficile à
pénétrer
il se forme s'évanouissent renaissent
les renseignements généraux un rite
pourtant à loger certains membres dans
la rafle de vendredi dernier ils ont
arrêté pascal trias impliqué dans le
meurtre de jean antoine tramoni avec un
autre ancien n'a pas passé au groupe
d'action directe jean marc rouillan 27
ans identifié malgré sa faculté de
changer de visage vous le voyez ici sous
trois aspects différents
c'est lui en compagnie de cette femme 23
ans en bas du cadre nathalie mini jean
23 ans donc qui arrose et au fusil
mitrailleur les fenêtres du bureau du
ministre de la coopération
le 18 mars dernier tous les deux sont
actuellement en fuite ainsi que deux
autres membres d'action directe
alain lemay 23 ans également et philippe
de ces à 26 ans tous deux tous quatre
sont en fuite ils sont activement
recherchés par les policiers
quant aux quatre italiens quant aux
quatre italiens pardon qui ont été
transférés la nuit dernière
harry l'italie a demandé leur
extradition le livre jeunesse la
politique la vérité est bien du côté de
georges marchais répète aujourd'hui dans
un communiqué le bureau politique du
parti communiste l'humanité va
d'ailleurs publié dit il une série de
témoignages et de preuves irréfutables
et communiste faisait là allusion aux
autres preuves publié ce matin par le
quotidien le matin sur un séjour de
georges marchais en urss en 1955 la
presse socialiste joue les premiers
rôles dans la conjuration de la bande
des trois il pesté michel rocard en
visite ce matin dans le fief de son ami
pierre mauroy c'est à dire dans le nord
pas de calais il a répété qu'il était
prêt à se ranger derrière françois
mitterrand si le premier secrétaire
était candidat économie revenons
maintenant sur les nouvelles normes
d'encadrement du crédit qui viennent
d'être publiés dans le journal officiel
des normes qui vont dans un sens
restrictif aussi bien pour les banques
que pour les particuliers ce pour lutter
contre l'inflation
mais cette fois vous êtes très nombreux
à être fonctionner puisque tous les
prêts complémentaires au titre de
l'épargne-logement vont être des
encadrait et il ya en france quelque 6
millions de titulaires de comptes ou de
plans d'épargne-logement pierre mariani
parmi les outils dont dispose le
gouvernement pour lutter contre
l'inflation
l'action sur le crédit est essentiel car
plus les banques accordent de crédit et
plus la masse de monnaie en circulation
donc l'inflation augmente
on peut bien sûr augmenter les taux
d'intérêt pour dissuader les emprunteurs
et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui se passe en
ce moment mais on peut en plus limiter
le crédit en quantité ou comme on dit
l'encadré devant l'aggravation de
l'inflation leur est manifestement à
l'encadrement et monsieur mono rivia
d'appuyer plus fortement sur ce frein
mais le freinage du crédit ne s'exerce
pas partout également du côté des
caisses d'epargne qui joue un rôle
important dans le crédit aux
particuliers
pas de changement elles ne sont pas
soumises à l'encadrement elles ne le
seront pas davantage dans l'avenir
l'essentiel de ce tour de vis sur les
prêts et notamment sur les prêts au
logement sera donc le fait des banques
qui ne feront pas d'ailleurs avec
plaisir puisque cela ralentira leurs
affaires concrètement pour les quelques
6 millions de français qui ont un plan
d'épargné logement
un compte d'épargné logement qu'est ce
qui va se passer une pourront plus
continuer écoutez le dans les six ou
sept prochains mois les comptes ou
plantes qui font arriver l'échéance vont
donner lieu pour leurs titulaires à la
possibilité d'obtenir un prêt principal
ça c'est de toute façon ça reste de
toute façon un produit intéressant
puisque ce prêt ils l'obtiendront à
trois ou à quatre et demi pour cent
suivant qu'il s'agit d'un compte ou d'un
plan ce qui est très ennuyeux c'est que
ses titulaires nous aurons beaucoup plus
de difficultés que par le passé à
obtenir un prêt complémentaire puisque
le gouvernement vient de décider
d'encadrer les précampagnes play
complémentaire de l'épargne-logement les
gens sont donc limités aux 150 mille
francs 15 millions anciens de voilà le
maximum de près que l'on peut obtenir
dit prêt principal dans le cadre de l'
épargne logement et de le 250 mille
francs et cela va beaucoup influé sur
l'activité des organismes bancaires sur
l'épargne-logement général ça va ça va
influencer à la baisse forcément
l'activité des établissements bancaires
des établissements financiers dans ce
domaine si on a plus de mal à obtenir un
crédit logement et notamment un prêt
complémentaire
il est clair que bien des gens vont
retarder leur projet d'achat ou de
rénovation de l'appartement ou de la
maison de leurs rêves
certains mêmes devront sans doute y
renoncer ce qui inquiète au plus haut
point
une autre catégorie de gens les
entrepreneurs du bâtiment
notre idée est d'abord de demander aux
gouvernements qui les prennent des
mesures et des mesures immédiates pour
les crédits qu'ils réservent au travers
d'un encadrement plus resserrée soit
affectée par priorité à notre activité
la construction c'est à dire les travaux
neufs et la réhabilitation et non pas à
des mesures telles que cela favorise la
spéculation sénat là notre premier souci
est dans la mesure où effectivement on
prend en compte nos soucis et bien il y
aura peut-être une réduction d'activité
moindre mais je dirais que dès à présent
si on ne prend pas ces mesures bien ya
un risque important que à terre ni les
cent mille emplois de moins dans notre
secteur et combien de
- dès à présent on peut en décompté au
moins trente mille si ce n'est davantage
marée noire alors que les militaires
poursuivent le travail gêné de ci de là
par l'arrivée de nouvelles plaques mais
un travail qui avance vite quand même
les aigus du trégor ont décidé de monter
à paris demain après midi une
manifestation les réunira place des
invalides à paris et ils seront épaulés
par un train spécial de protestataires
en provenance de bretagne pétrole
toujours si je puis dire pour empêcher
une chute du prix de l'or noir certains
pays membres de l'opep ont décidé de
réduire leur production
c'est le cas par exemple du koweït qui
va diminuer de 25% ses exportations
énergie toujours demain en vrai giraud
exposera devant le conseil des ministres
les perspectives énergétiques de la
france pour les dix années à venir
le miz industrie sera l'invité de notre
journal demain à 20 heures il
l'expliquera les choix du gouvernement
est parmi les questions que nous lui
poserons bien sur l'avenir des mines de
charbon les mines sont elles
définitivement condamné ou bien les
hausses successives du pétrole en route
elle certaines plus compétitive
aujourd'hui par exemple une cinquantaine
de mineurs du bassin des cévennes sont
montés à paris pour manifester contre la
fermeture dans quinze jours 2 2 puis
délaisse une fermeture lourde de
conséquences pour toute cette région
c'est à reportage de jean pellieux et de
claude sicard et on était 200 lampes 11
cents mineurs qui travaillaient au fond
de la mine est cinq ou six ans employée
à la surface ce qui représente largement
la population ouvrière du bassin des
cévennes actuelle
c'est dire comment la récession nous a
frappés mais malheureusement dans 74 2
malgré la grève des mineurs
tout le personnel a été muté l année
puis 2 destival de la grand combe qui
restait encore dans les cévennes et on a
fait ses originalités le puits de saint
florent
alors vous avez apporté les fautes voilà
moi j'ai ont jugé le plus tel qu'il est
et le trou qui est derrière nous et qui
a été comblée voilà notre puits de mine
et voilà le le jour le 15 avril ce qu'il
en est advenu 15 avril 75
mais s'il faisait ici de tournon 700 à
l'homme c'était un bus qui fonctionnait
très bien
après saint florent la direction ferme
il y a deux ans le puits ricard au nord
d'alès sur 21 puis à la libération deux
seulement sont aujourd'hui opérationnels
et sur vingt-et-un mineurs il en reste
quatorze cents dans les cévennes dont
300 mineurs de fond le faible rendement
de tonnes par hommes oblige l'état a
subventionné le charbon pour moitié
il serait rentable réplique les mineurs
si on exploitait intensivement les
gisements le fond ferment cette année
l'exploitation se poursuivra en surface
ou le rendement est cette fois plus
grand mais la production 500 mille
tonnes actuellement aura dans trois ans
diminué de moitié
quant aux mineurs en trop on les invite
à partir en retraite ou à se reconvertir
mais si en 20 ans avec l'aide de l'état
la région a créé quelques 6000 emplois
elle en a perdu 13 milles ce qui incite
élus et chefs d'entreprises à se
mobiliser
malheureusement depuis la prise comme
n'avons plus connu n'est ce pas
les enfants n'ont pas été récupéré et je
crois et qui serait indispensable que
les pouvoirs publics se préoccupent
situation et puis ceux implantés des
industries importantes ont fermé en gros
tous les emplois perdus faute de succès
industriel et vu ce qu'il y as ou leur
sol légende à l'aise croient encore au
charbon
la région vient d'ailleurs de voter des
crédits pour sa relance mais l'état s'y
refuse reprise des négociations entre la
sécu de social et la fédération des
médecins de france la caisse d'assurance
maladie des salariés espèrent conclure
une nouvelle convention avant le 30
avril
les producteurs de lait français et
belges ont manifesté aujourd'hui à
londres pour protester contre le refus
anglais d'importer du lait après avoir
distribué 600 litres de lait à des
londoniens assez surpris les
manifestants se sont rendus devant le
parlement et à nice où une bousculade
s'est produite avec la police deux
agriculteurs aux été arrêtés et
condamnés pour désordre public
mais une délégation a quand même été
reçu par le ministre britannique de
l'agriculture les pneus v10 et v12
kléber collant ne seront pas retirés du
service après une longue enquête et de
nombreux examens les pouvoirs publics
estime qu'on ne peut pas parler de
défaut trawick à sion d'une mauvaise
conception c'est une mise au point qui
fait suite à la campagne lancée contre
kléber colombes par l'union fédérale des
consommateurs à la suite d'éclatement
suspect de ses pneus à moscou
réapparition delienne brejnev à
l'occasion de la remise du prix lénine
il lui avait été attribuée en décembre
dernier pour l'ensemble de son oeuvre
kelly brejnev qui a l'air très fatigué
qui a quand même parlé d'une quinzaine
de minutes sans interruption
alors alain gillot-pétré ce prix lénine
qui a déjà couronné dans le passé des
écrivains de talent et ils n'auraient
pas pense vraiment important et puis le
prix lénine dans quelque sorte le prix
nobel des pays de l'est il est attribué
depuis 1956 et a couronné en effet des
écrivains considérable exclusivement
soviétique est systématiquement de
l'appareil d'état comme michail sur le
kof
auteur du don paisible un très bel
ouvrage constata simonov vous va si vite
chose qu'ils relèvent leur fille suite à
la demande des travailleurs
c'est un endiguement m'écouter voici la
totalité des oeuvres complètes in
extenso et en un volume de leonid
brejnev à la pointe du combat
paru chez hachette cet ouvrage regroupe
les trois livres du loria d'aujourd'hui
la petite terre souvenir des combats d
armée du front du caucase du nord et de
la flotte de la mer noire lors du
débarquement de nouveaux rossi ce qu'en
1943 renaissance à suite ardeurs compte
rendu du rétablissement de l'appareil
industriel soviétique lourdement
endommagés dans la région de sapporo
gier les sous titres n'ont pas faim les
terres vierges ou le labeur quotidien
des pionniers d'un sovkhoze sur les
terres en friche du kazakhstan vous dire
que s'est livrée la densité et la
surface littéraire dans un autre genre
de l'archipel du goulag de soljenitsyne
serait peut-être exagéré leonid brejnev
ne fait pas profession d'être écrivain
mais indiscutablement ces lignes sont de
sa main le vocabulaire est accessible à
tous sur tous les adjectifs
le style est direct sans fioritures et
je voudrais un tout petit exemple très
rapide ont levé du jour nous filions
déjà en voiture sur la route lorsqu'on
nous informa que devant nous notre
aviation attaquer les unités allemandes
le sixième sens qui est sans doute celui
des gens constamment danger me fais
crier
couchez vous les gars ça va chauffer
ccfd
c'est assez déroutant en tout cas ça a
plu aux académiciens du prix lénine de
littérature qui sont nommés pour trois
ans et payés par le gouvernement
soviétique lors tout cas j'espère que
vous ça vous plaira puisque je veux j'en
fais catho mais c'est gentil merci
beaucoup
tennis tournoi de monte carlo
aujourd'hui les ténors sont entrés en
lice borg a battu mcnamara en deux sets
très facilement et vilas en deux sets
également 6 3 6 3 a éliminé l'italien
panatta à partir de demain comédie vous
pourrez suivre ce tournoi en direct sur
antenne 2 commenté par hervé duthu la
météo et bien aujourd'hui le temps a été
doux mais très nuageux sur la plus
grande partie du pays la plus sur toute
la moitié nord
demain il pleuvra le matin des ardennes
et des vosges jusqu'au limousin le soir
c'est pluie atteindront les alpes les
rouges la manche et le nord du massif
central sur les régions de l'ouest
on peut espérer toutefois des éclaircies
le soir je vous laisse regarder là comme
promis maintenant je vais vous révéler
pourquoi nos deux petits camarades sont
avec nous sur ce plateau ce mardi 1er
avril je pense que le jour s'imposer
alors vous connaissez vous les
connaissez tous d'abord à ma droite
kermit la grenouille qui est un homme
contrairement à ce qu'on peut imaginer
ce que la grenouille c'est du masculin
en anglais et puis à ma gauche
là je porte cette part est assez évident
à ma gauche piggy la [ __ ] et
l'ensemble c'est l'émeute est c'est à
dire la partie émergée d'un immense
iceberg que vous découvrez depuis un bon
bout de temps sur antenne 2 le répète
chaud et ses deux petites camarades et
ses deux petits camarades s'ils sont là
pour lancer leur film car aujourd'hui
depuis tout à l'heure sur les écrans
parisiens et de province
on découvre en effet leur film c'est
leur premier film le film qui dure une
heure et demie s'appelle les muppets ou
simplement et les deux grandes stars des
me pète sont venus vendre leurs films
sont venus à paris se promener dans les
avenues les plus prestigieuses dans les
bars les plus chics et dans les hôtels
les plus luxueux et vous allez vivre
cette journée s'ils ont vécu en
compagnie de gérard holtz et de bernard
poussot vous allez le voir c'est assez
chouette et ça commence ce matin dans un
grand hôtel parisien un américain à
paris plus une belle américaine égale
embouteillages
attroupement sur les champs-elysées pour
l'escapade parisienne démo pèse des
véritables stars internationales kermit
d'abord le premier et le plus célèbre
des muppets un savant mélange de l'homme
du monde et du petit garçon et puis miss
piggy piggy la [ __ ] dont on parle de
plus en plus pour un oscar à hollywood
coquette capricieuse sophistiqué bref
l'image même d'un certain type de femme
qui laisse rarement insensible les
hommes même les plus raisonnables et
même les plus sérieux au show business
oblige déjeuner dans un grand restaurant
avec au menu pour nous un petit gag en
supplément ça c'est l'union 4,71
mais c'est un excellent choix un subtil
de qualité merci
ouais si séoul et kick tester
problème cela ne vous convient pas
écoutez on va changer alors
vous proposez celui ci
non plus wes beauté je pense que ceci
fera la sphère jim henson
quelle est la différence entre le muppet
show que l'on voit à la télévision et le
film des muppets dans l'émission
télévisée
c'est l'invité qui compte dans le décor
dans le monde des mots fait dans le film
qu'au contraire ce sont les mots pet qui
sont dans notre monde à nous on a tourné
beaucoup de scènes en extérieur par
exemple et les pieds tu peux te débattre
tant que tu voudras gré d autant
transformer une dépendront et maintenant
on va mettre l'autre calanques et richie
il y aura bien assez de voltage qui
traversera cette petite cervelle et
grenouilles pour allumer cincinnati
cauchon qui peuvent dire adieu à ton
petit copain pourquoi parce que dans un
peu moins de big c quand il croira que
dieu cacher petits boudins blancs
qu'est ce que c'est pas si une [ __ ]
qui fait du kung fu c'est une maison de
fous ça va plus à kermit heures vous
pourrez retrouver les muppets la semaine
prochaine dans l'émission de guy lux sur
antenne 2 dont 38 avant journal les
autres rendez vous que vous avez avec
l'actualité plus sérieuse ce soir pire
alain pour le dernier journal à 23h30
demain pantone riboud sera l'invité de
nos traditions de 12h45
et puis je vous retrouverai moi même
dans une dizaine de jours dix jours que
vous passerez alternativement compagnie
de daniel bilalian et de lyon zitrone à
moins que les deux stagiaires que nous
avons engagé ce soir camille tpiy qui se
révèlent meilleurs excellente soirée à
tous bonsoir je vous laisse à leur
compagnie